Herkese
merhaba olduğum için aşırı mutluyum
aşırı da rahat Şimdi öncelikle bir zaten
biz bize bir şeyi sormak istiyorum Böyle
hiçb ş bisiklete binmemiş var mı Son bir
yıl hiç Tamam birlikte
konuşalım Onun dışında son bir yıl
içerisinde en az bir kere bisiklete
BİM güzel herkes iste O zaman az buz
hatırlıyor yani hani yabancı bir şey
anlatmayacağım size şimdi size
anlatacağım yolculuk birazcık Aslında
bisikletle Yaptığım bu
yolculukta bisikletin icat olarak
Aslında nasıl bir fark
yarattığını size anlatmak istiyorum
şimdi bisiklet 1800'lerin başlarında
Love Machine diye
Almanların icat ettiği bir ürün Peki ne
diye baktığımız zaman mesela şu grafiği
inceleyelim bu Duke University bir
araştırması
ve aşağıda solda of trans diyor
ama baz olarak söylüyor ve baktığınız
zaman bu grafik Neyi gösteriyor aslında
y kilog yer değiştirmesi için kaç kalori
harcıyorsun ne demek bu verim
demeki olar baktığım birane ğe bakıma
helikopter var SAÜ e otomobil var biraz
altında Jet Fighter var
E hayvanlar var ilginç bir şekilde
Rabbit var dog var ondan sonra ve biraz
aşağı indiğinizde at var ve hepsinin
altında Men on
bicycle şimdi bu aslında yavaş yavaş bir
sinyali vermeye başlıyor neyin sinyalini
vermeye başlıyor bisiklet zaten
düşündüğünüz zaman yani çok basit ve
Yalın bir mekanizma
Yani bu basit ve Yalın Bir mekanizmanın
da açıkçası zaten kendi içinde çok
kompleks tüketimleri yok rezistans düşük
böyle baktığımız zaman da aslında bir
noktadan sonra en organik ulaşım çeşidi
olmaya başladığını görüyoruz Peki bunu
aynı zamanda devam ettirirsek bisiklet
bu noktada Bir de bizim için böyle doğ
en baş başa anımızı temsil ediyor Şimdi
size Bu yaptığım yolculuktan kısa bir
video
izletecek
oh
şimdi videonun sonunda gördüğünüz o
derin karda ilerlediğim sahne var ya
aslında Oraya kadar olan sahnelerin
birçoğu zaten nispeten daha kurak
Yağmurlu havalarda geçiyor ama bu
videoda gördüğünüz sahneler aşağı yukarı
yolculuğumun 5i civarı bir havayı temsil
ediyor yolculuğun geri kalan kısmı
Aslında -2 derece etrafında gezen bir
soğukta geçiyor Ve böyle bir soğuğun
içerisinde bizim aslında hazırlıksız
Olduğumuz şey pilleri nasıl ısıtacağım O
yüzden de aslında çekimler büyük
çoğunlukla nispeten -1 derece ve
etrafındakilere hitap ediyor burada da
gördüğünüz Peki şimdi mesela bu resim
üzerinden bakalım burası vakam Vadisi
ben size yolculuğu çok az tarif edeyim
duşan
beden Tacikistan'ın başkentidir
Tacikistan Hani Afganistan Tacikistan
Kırgızistan Pakistan diye düşünürseniz
Tacikistan kentinden başlıyor ve ondan
sonra Kırgızistan'da
bik bitiyor m41 denen pamil Highway diye
bir Rota bu eee çok ciddi 1930'lardan
beri devam eden klasik bir radır 4700
metreye varan bir yüksekliği var Ve
şimdi Rota olarak düşündüğünüz zaman a
noktasından B noktasına İlerleyen bir
rotadan bahsediyorum e a noktasından B
noktasına ilerlemesinde de şöyle bir
örnek vereyim Bu resim a noktası gibi
kirsiz Vadisi Burası dağların arasın
giriyorsunuz Dağların arasında vadisinde
yaklaşık 20 gün 2000 metrelerde devam
ediyorsunuz Ondan sonra başlıyor 3000
3000'den sonra 4000 geliyor ve 4000l
kadar bütün bu yolculuk boyunca A'dan
B'ye giderken tamamen
As bir y şöyle söyleyeyim
Bu asfalt görmediğiniz süreden sonra
4344 karş denen bir zirveyle
karşılaşıyorsunuz Ondan sonrasında da
4.000 metre üzerinde yavaş yavaş yol
almaya başlıyorsunuz yaklaşık 12 gün
boyunca 4000 metre üzerinde herhangi
hiçbir sinyal olmadan herhangi hiçbir
canlı olmadan hiçbir insan olmadan
bayağı ay yüzeyinde Yaşar gibi devam
ediyorsunuz Peki bu A'dan B'ye gidersen
ve sonra da bişkek'e doğru Kırgızistan'a
doğru tekrar devam ediyorsunuz
Tacikistan a B'den A'ya gidersen ne
oluyor tam tersini yapalım B'den A'ya
gidersen 4000 metreye asfalt üzerinden
yaklaşıyorsun asfalt üzerinden yaklaştık
sonra nispeten daha fazla inişi olan
daha az çıkışı olan Çünkü yol hem bu
şekilde hem de tırmanıyor aynı anda
şimdi böyle düşündüğünüz zaman B'den
A'ya nispeten daha avantajlı bir radır
tek Karşıdan
gel karı gitmek
açıkçı cdi bir sorun ve
bununla
K
HS kenden hiç
şey
fırsat düğünü zaman
Bu kadar yani sessizliğin içerisinde
Mesa ALC insan düş vak
ol
sisik
gü s seler içer
bisikle düşüm ki
yan ulaşım arı
ol
arıana
ne bir bunu dönüştürme y bisik
ner Bakı zaman bu met sizinle paylaşmak
isterim şimdi bu aşağıda gördüğünü gri
kısım hayattaki en saf şans anı olarak
değerlendirdim nedir bu doğduğumuz an
bir Piyango kazanırsın bir şey olur her
şey olabilir yani hayatta bir anda
şuradan meteor düşer bir şey olur ama
baktığın zaman bunların hepsine olasılık
diyebilirsin randomness diyebilirsin her
şeyi söyleyebilirsin Ama şans olarak pür
kabul edeceğin bir an varsa o da
doğduğun an bazılarımız asfaltta doğuyor
rezistansı düşük ve devam ediyor
bazılarımız kumda doğuyor ve ben bu
yolculuk içerisinde galiba her zemeni
gördüm suda da ilerledik buzda da
ilerledik buz üstü karda da ilerledik
bazın ilerlemedi ve ittik Ama tek bir
şey vardı Hiç Durmadık Çünkü koşulları
unutmayın çok soğuk şimdi zemin bu pür
şans anını temsil ediyor ve Aslında
çeşitli rezistansları olabilir ama her
zaman devam etmek zorundasın peki
pedalları düşünelim
birt Çü
şöyle gün içer güne burada duruyor
bisik gmii için önce ayak parmak
uçlarımda sonra ayağımda ciddi bir soğuk
ısırı tehlikesi başlıyor ve soğuk
ısırığını şöyle izah edeyim dolaşım
duruyor yavaş yavaş morarmaya başlıyor
ve Ondan sonrasında buzları kaybetmeye
başlıyorsunuz şimdi bu senaryoya
girmemek için her 15 dakikada bir
iniyorsunuz koşuyorsunuz ısınma
hareketleri yapıyorsunuz dolaşımınızı
canlandırıyorsunuz vesaire ama böyle bir
soğuktan bahsederken ped ned temsil
ediyor Çünkü hiçb şekilde durmamak
zorundalar Eğer böyle bir soğukta
duruyor şurada bir durayım bir nefesim
ded 3 saniye
son saniye
son içine
zaten o yüzden pedallar zaman ve asla
durmamalı ve güne ve soğuk bunun
Aslında s
bakımi Eskiden diyordum biraz eleştiri
al Ondan sonra eski kız
arkadaşlar ama şey sen geçmişini temsil
ediyor nasıl temsil ediyor şöyle tems
ediyor geçmişinin üzerinde rahat hareket
et lazım Böyle bir
yolculukta bütün yani hayatının tamamı
bir tulumda selenin üstünde geçiyor O
yüzden de düşündüğünüz zaman asında buin
sana konforlu biriş
ve geiş seni gel yığılan biridir
veek Ama sen bir Par
ondan
gelenü
sen4
sen
hağ yani en küçü vites senin dü kar
yoks en küük
vites en küçük vitesini koruyorsun ve
her yokuşa daha fazla antrenman yapmaya
başlıyorsun
yokuşların varlığı İsa Aslında
senaryolar kısmı ona birazdan geleceğim
Son iki parçaya gelelim birincisi beyin
beyin gidon gidon ne direksiyon ve yani
gidon la ilgili söyleyebileceğimiz ne
var Birincisi hakikaten ne yöne
gittiğini anlık olarak kontrol eder
ikincisi bütün engellerin etrafından
seni o geçirir üçüncüsü bisikleti o mu
götürür Hayır
kales İnelim bir ne aane gittiğimiz
Rotayı yaklaş 35000 met yani 8000 35000
met tırmanış bahsi çünü inişler ve çıkış
yol ve bütün zirveler 35 met tırmandığın
aan B'ye ol birden ol daha az Tırman ama
yüzünüzden
Gelin bu bu fotoğrafı gerçekten çok
seviyorum çünkü gerçekten iyi anlatıyor
Kırgızistan'da alab geçidinde -30
derecede bir fırtına patladı
ve o sırada Hipotermi riski geçirmek
üzere olan bir arkadaşımız sebebiyle
orada yolculuğu tekrar durdurduk ve geri
çıktık fırtınadan yola devam etmedik
Kazakistan dümdüz Mesela bu bir tırmanış
bu 3000 met üstünde Kazakistan'da
dümdüz yani böyle son
gyor ama sonza kar gidiyor
ve biz saatte 4 K GB Normalde 6 K yakın
bir yazı yürüyorsunuz 4 k yani
söyleyeceğim şey şu bu fotoğ
Kırgızistan aynı şek Pak
vesa kığ
düme gi
eer s fark etmek gereken
Şaş yavaş düşün nee göre kar veriyorsun
karşı geliyor Ne görüyorsun şur engi
görüyorum onlar atıyorum tekram
bural
bir kar veri gördüğüm Sadece bu
kadar Eğer beyninin görüş alanını
buren yavaş yavaş
başkaş ne Doğuş endişe doğm neree g
bilmi bir kapalı alanın içerisinde
ilerliyor
lise 2'den lise 4'e kadar yaklaşık 2 yıl
orada yaklaşık 2 yılda üniversitede ne
yapacağımı düşündüm ve tam olarak bu
şekilde gitme anında onu hatırladım
şurada şu fırtınanın
içinde Çünkü olay öyleydi yani istediğim
cevabı
göremiyordum ve böyle gidiyormuş gibi
durmadan bir şeyler atlıyorum sınavlar
geçiyor o geçiyor bu geçiyor hayatan her
şey
geçiyor ve ben
nere g bilmed bir engel aşı Hay bana ne
geti hayat ne geti onun etrafından
geçi Bu bir ilerleme çeş
değil işte o noktada ne yapmam
gerektiğini bu
yolculukta O noktada yaptığım şey şyd
rüzg karı ilerlerken
hip kar
iler
RG kar iler kar ilek kar farkı Hani
Hayta
zorı
yac kötü hissettiğin anlar vard
gi ve ciddi bir acı
veriyor
yani o yokuşları
k
hiss oan
son senaryoya geçelim yokuş çık rüz
çıkarken eğ yoku çıkarken yun yoku çıkm
baadi mesak
VK bitird dağlar arasınd ve yavaş yavaş
GD Ne yapıyorsun Bir kere durun Durak
çok Kaf bir şe söylüyorsun ben oraya Şu
saatte varım bu kadar sürede varım bu
kadar Efor ğım takımım hazır mı Her
Şeyim Tamam ve
baş işte yokuş çıkmanın yavaş yavaş
Aslında fark ettirdiği
şey hangi vitesi ayarlaman gerektiğini
önce düşündü ondan son ne kadar sürede
aşağ yavaş yava Yokun
sona ve
seb Yokuşu görünce vazgeçmemek çünkü
onun tek şansın yapmak senin elinde ve
Ondan sonrasında o yokuş çıkmaya sebat
etmek de senin elinde rüzgardan en büyük
farkı ise kafanı kaldırıp Gittiğin yeri
görüyorsun ve beynin bütün olasılıkların
içerisinde hareket ederken oraya doğru
gidiyor Şimdi böyle düşündüğümüz zaman
her yokuşun Bu sebeple de bir vitesi
olması gerekir ve o zaman a noktas işte
B noktasına gidebiliyorsun yokuştur
odada ha bu size ne veriyor bu kadar
yokuş çıkmaya sebat etmek işte böyle bir
şey
veriyor bu 4655 metrede Oliver yolculuk
arkadaşım e Fransız onunla birlikte
verdiğimiz kz Ve inanılmaz kötü bir
fırtınayı atlattıktan
sonra çok ciddi bir tehlike atlattıktan
sonra bir sonraki gün en yüksek yani
dünyanın en yüksek ikinci yolunun en
yüksek noktasına yaklaştığımızda bir an
bütün dağların arasınd tekrar Biz çıktık
ve İşte o zaman yokuşun üstü vardığında
o manzara o özgürlük
hissi işte senin zaten motivasyon oluyor
bir sonak yokuşa geldiğinde zaten o
özgürlük hissi için devam ediyorsun
Çünkü biliyorsun ki o Yokuşu çıkmaya seb
edersen o Yokuşu
çıkarsa
seni
ve orada yavaş yavaş beynini özgür
bırakmak dediğim bu etrafına bakarak
yokuşları çıkmaya Sebat etme durumu
yavaş yavaş seni özgürleşti ama bu
özgürleşmeyi de bu arada Gerçekten
yalnız yapıyor yani seni ıssızlığın
içerisinde tek başına bırakıyor Bu da
benim kanaatim Açıkçası bu
ıssızlık birey olmanın başladığı
nokta birey olmak da
k veyahutta Ben bunu
kaldıramayanlar için de kendime mesela
bu yolculukta çok güzel bir trik bulum
onu da sizinle paylaşacağım Çünkü
hepimizin galiba hayatında bulabileceği
Eee rutinler
biri burada biraz ışığı
kapatabilirsin şu küçük ışık Benim
çadırım şu an bu resmin olduğu yer
Afganistan
Eee ve Afganistan'da dağların altında
iki dağın arasında
gü musunuz bilmiyorum ama
samol bizim yaptığım şd
Sam sığım ş Eğer p
ağ
heru
gi
iz
Emet bana tekr umut tekrar gökyüzünü
görmek ve şunu sö her gün gece olac ve
her gece tekrar gün
OLED hiç
durm kayed günüm yok
ğe
Ama bu doğayı takl etmek değil sadece
doğanın içerisinde hareket etmek aynı
zamanda o yüzden de bizim yaptığımız
Yani bizim hayatımızın içerisinde
doğanın yerleştirdiği metaforları
görmeye çalışın ve
Aslında yavaş yavaş beyniniz Özgür
bıraktıkça da bu hepimizin içerisinde
olan Gökyüzünde Benim bulduğum
kizim
eü dediğim cümle Yarın yine olacak fedal
yine hiç durmayacak ve doğadan öğrenecek
çok şeyin var ama metaforlar hepimizin
kendi içinde o yüzden de tutkularımız
gizli olan bu
metaforlara özgür bir beyinle çok net
ulaşabiliyoruz hepinizin tutkularının
yolu açık olsun teşekkür
ederim
than